the heading today is travel graphs if
you haven't written it already the date
of course is the 11th of November what
you were just doing with that guy
shooting out of Canon and what's the
second one what we bumper cars and then
the third one was yeah a ferris wheel
type thing for all three of those
situations what you are creating was a
graph that shows how an object travels
and so that's why I very originally we
call them travel graphs now we've just
got a few pointers about them and then
we're going to see how we can use it
interpret them okay so you can see I've
just got down here the side here some
helpful notes to take along which will
summarize and formalize what we've all
just experienced but putting into some
language okay so first thing think about
last year actually maybe even that you
before that we met the Cartesian plane
do you remember that the Cartesian plane
it's got a vertical axis it's got a
horizontal axis what do you usually call
has a name what do we usually call the
horizontal axis what letter do we
usually use the X right we call this one
the X and then we call this one bar Y
fantastic we call them X and y because
they can stand for anything in this case
and you probably saw it on your screen
the horizontal axis we don't call it X
what do we call it it's time and then
what we had on the vertical axis with
something to do with distance always to
might thank you now I do say something
to do with distance because it's
different kinds of distances isn't it I
think with the guy shooting out of the
cannon and also with the ferris wheel it
was just an up/down distance but the
bumper cars didn't have anything to do
with up-and-down what distance were they
trying to get you to measure have a
thing because it had a reed winding path
do you remember that you know it's kind
of my length traveled right like just
how far have you gone didn't keep matter
which way okay but you've got a distance
and a time axis and that's what kind of
characterizes a travel graph and then
you can do you know whatever you like
from there I think that's something like
what we created for ketamine did you get
something like that yeah okay now it's
very important that we learn to
interpret a graph that's already given
to us as well as construct our own
so there's kind
few features on a travel graph that
probably you know how to interpret for
example here's a different travel graph
there are some sections on the graph
here and here that are horizontal what
does that mean about well in this case
it's um a woman cycling what does it
mean about that person when you see the
horizontal section Jessica yeah just
this part here what does that mean
yeah perfect she's having a break she
stopped cycling may be having lunch
whatever the important thing is it's
horizontal because come back to this
graph right the distance at that time is
not changing to see that it's not going
up it's not going down so what we would
say is when you're horizontal on the
graph that's when you stop we've got a
fancy word for stop which is stationary
I heard it so when you use the word
stationary and you spell it with an a
not with an e I'm holding stationary in
my hands with a name but when
something's not moving when it stopped
it's stationary with an A okay so that's
what you mean when it says when there's
a horizontal part um what does it mean
when a part of the graph is really steep
like I'm thinking back to for example at
the beginning of cannon man you all drew
a very steep graph what does that mean
what does it indicate he's going really
said again him he's going really far a
big vertical change in a small amount of
time so I guess we could say that that's
a fast motion right the steeper it is
the faster is going therefore what would
you guess the shallow thing means it's
it's slow which is why I'll just come
back to this graph here whoops too many
things on my double you see this end
part of the graph you all drew a perfect
kind of it leveled out why did it level
out what happened to the guy coming out
of a cannon good say Paul his parachute
which as you would hope slowed him down
okay very good
now one last thing before we then have a
look at this travel graph and answer
some questions about it it's in a weed
question how many dimensions are there
on this graph any suggestions who
reckons there's two dimensions heads-up
okay I'm County about ten hands guy
think he has down and who thinks there's
a different number of dimensions not to
anyone
okay so somebody put their hand up
before which was most of you what are
the dimensions horizontal and vertical
can we come back to Kenan for a second
right which way did Kenan man
travel where did he go up and then down
how many dimensions is that it's just
it's just one right up and down is one
dimension we could have gone left right
I guess does kind of man go that's right
he actually doesn't what's a third
dimension the third one we live in its
not up down not left right it's a depth
right so I guess we could say forward
backward right now none of these
dimensions come into play though you
have a question or a thought this is the
question what do we mean by a dimension
well we mean a direction you can move a
direction you can I should say move in
yeah it's an interesting question
actually dimension is kind of like a
little more technically specific um you
know when you say you've got a like an
object which has volume right you say
has dimensions but it might not move
anywhere so we don't have to say it has
a direction if that makes sense now what
I really want to get across to you here
is our travel graphs at least the ones
we're looking at they only have one
dimension of movement one dimension of
movement even though you've got a 2d
graph what is the second dimension
there's no movement happening
horizontally what is this it's it's the
flow of time isn't it right in this case
you can see it's hours on a clock so
these are the things we need to know to
interpret this let's have a look go up
especially to see if we can answer them
together and I'm actually going to
answer them on the page you don't need
to redraw the graph but I'm going to
point to the part on the graph that are
relevant this is min eek
like I said and she's cycling at what
time did Minnie Cleve home so this is
the start of the journey have a look I
know it's said again damn man o'clock so
that's the start right so if you want to
pop in your book right actually going to
put down here cuz it's closer to where
that is
where do I get nine o'clock from it's
where the graph begins horizontally is
that okay so I'm gonna say 9:00 a.m. and
I get it from right there when Wisman
eeks first stop and how far from home
was she so this is a double-barreled
question David you wanna give us the
first half and then I'll go to someone
else to give me the second half when was
Monique's first stop 11:00 a.m. so
here's where we're reading across how do
we know it's 11:00 by the way where okay
very good so if I go up like that sorry
it's kind of a little bit wonky right
and lines up with I think was Jessica
she said that horizontal part of the
graph which means a stop okay so we can
say Part B at 11:00 a.m. there was the
second half what are we asked yeah
fantastic so how far and we can read
from the vertical axis right 40
kilometers from home okay let's switch
colors here so this'll do all right so
we can know what time she stops and how
far away she was and we're gonna combine
those for his next question it says find
her average speed over the first two
hours which is actually the same as when
she took her first break so how do we
work out to be this is what we were
looking at last lesson right so handy
how we calculate speed okay so we've got
this triangle here right what are the
three parts its distance and then speed
and then time right so you might find
this helpful
if you don't that's okay I often go to
like how do we measure the speed if you
were traveling on a car and us in a
bicycle right what's the measurement the
unit of speed what would you say women
or yeah that's okay join it John a bad
off to someone else
Louise what would you say is the unit of
speed km/h will do so if I say
kilometers per hour do you see that's
distance divided by time yeah so what
have I got here how far has she gone
over in these two hours
she's gone yeah we just established it
hey 40 kilometers in two hours is the
same as 20 kilometers in one okay so far
so good
just a quick thing I'm going to point
out you ever you guys told me I'm going
to change the color here you guys told
me that the steep of the graph is that
means the faster you're going right so
you've got that 40 divided by this too
so what you're looking at is that
gradient is the name we should say for
it which we're going to look at in
further years okay
there's Part C I'm going to pause for a
second and I'm going to let you have a
look at D and E yourself and then we'll
come back together and then we'll finish
our F and G I'll just read it for you in
case it's a bit hard to see D says what
time was it when Minnie began her
journey you can do it in your own book
what time was it when Minnie began her
journey home I'll let you find it on the
graph part e says how far does she
travel all together have a go at those
two and then we'll come back together
I'll give you about one minute